and that does it for us - be sure to
tune in and see
back at all the matter this week have a
great weekend you want to say anything
to those accusers the people that's
accusing you of all these wrongdoings
the wave of sexual abuse allegations
we've been reporting has now touched CBS
news
CBS News has fired our former co-anchor
over allegations of sexual misconduct
you can't understate you know the level
of influence and power that a man like
Charlie Rose has some say he groped them
or exposed himself to them and many
paint a picture of a respected figure
abusing his position let me be very
clear there is no excuse for this
alleged behavior it is systematic and
pervasive Charlie does not get a pass
here he doesn't get a pass from anyone
in this room we are all deeply affected
we are all walked by there the Border
Patrol Council said that these two
agents were ambushed we have to stop the
massive drug flow from boring in Charles
Manson died last night at a California
hospital led a group of young followers
he instructed them to kill seven people
no one knows what happened to the sub
that ocean turns out to be a very large
ocean if you're looking in the wrong box
what a memory this is this was right to
the very end
you're supposed to go to Americans and
South Carolinians are going to Romanians
and people who Czech Republic are you
going to set up their interview not like
this a long time essentially I mean you
saw the door closed yes but it's one of
those moments reads like where is the
elevator believe me
Alabama's officers doing push-ups with a
canine named Nitro no Nitro oh no
question
so you think there's gonna be an
explosion in this and we think there's
gonna be people building these types of
buildings all over they're already
building a number of them in Portland
you're gonna see them all over you need
food you need football and you need this
parade been talking about all morning I
mean this is like the only subject thing
that he can talk about one of the
busiest travel days of the year you can
take your turkey in your carry-on but
you have to check the great okay I'll
remember that
triple-a acknowledges they'd still get
calls about flat tires regardless
because about one in five of us don't
actually know how to change a tire I
don't you know I've never done that
thank you Chris family will call me gala
[Music]
have you ever done anything like that
but I did I jumped with the golden
knights of the army about ten years you
know I think two in a lifetime is enough
I loved it I know they find it
invigorating but I think I'm goodness
Cuba has a nostalgic feeling and you
don't realize there's you know from the
10 million people then there's kids
there and they won't be part of it in
the world they want to feel like they're
part of what we're doing and it did feel
like this is their moment
[Music]
Oh
[Music]